好 大家早上好 我這個圖其實代表了很多東西
那個最近的這個市場 我覺得很多層面上是政策和
不是經濟吧 就是政策和這個完全是政治政策的影響
所以觀測的整個重心就從上個星期或再上個星期
這兩個月以來基本上都是特朗普的tariff 就是他關稅政策
那麼這個關稅政策呢 上週有很多的變化
市場變得有很大的這個波動 其實一方面是股市場的波動
另外一方面有債券的波動 所以債券這個市場問得比較多
就說到底美國國債是不是發生了什麼問題
那麼美國利率市場會怎麼樣 那這個呢我待會會回答一下
我覺得本質上來說呢 不用太多
是一個很大的很大的那個de-laverage 很大的去鋼桿
但是呢 歷史上以前也發生過
但是對美國國債市場不會造成一個特別大的影響
那麼這兩位同志呢 就特朗普同志就說
特朗普同志把那個中國的關稅加到125了
所以你可以看一下他在周末的一些鬧劇的變化
就說先是給中國加了關稅嘛 然後中國反制了他
中國先反制了他之後呢 他又加了 加了之後呢
中國好像加到84啊 加到多少
然後特朗普就把中國加到125
那麼其實上週有一個很大relief rally
就是那個很大的一個反彈
從那個 我記得上週還是上週一還是幾啊
那個納斯達克有反彈了將近12個點
那麼這個反彈呢
就是說特朗普把其他國家的關稅全部取消了
也不是取消吧 只不過特朗普加到10%了
就說我們Grace到三個月90天
90天以後呢 然後再來看
然後把那個關稅呢基本上都加在中國人頭上
中國人的125%
其實呢就是一個人在搞校園霸凌
然後呢 有個人不給大家保護費
他說把你們保護費全取消了
然後呢 大家一起去杯葛他 去搞那個搞中國去
那麼這件事情的結果會怎麼樣
我覺得先說一下我覺得大的形式的判斷
就這個非常長遠的一個結果
那麼這個結果我覺得是中國和美國
現在丟失了每一份貿易份額
都沒有辦法被捕回來
但是這是一個很長期的view
就是這個事情我對長期是非常悲觀
那麼但是對於短期來說呢
特朗普現在加的所有的關稅政策
它是沒有辦法執行的
你不要說 比如說給中國原產地標注一個碼
那些東西能夠是中國產的
然後運到哪些國家
然後轉口貿易再怎麼過來
然後怎麼去加這些關稅
包括你所有的轉口貿易的國家
包括歐洲在內 日本在內
墨西哥加上大 有一個算一個
那麼這些國家
它要在立法給中國加關稅是很麻煩的
它要把原來自己WTO的這個體制給突破掉
然後在中國加關稅是需要通過它議會的
人家不是你美國弄一個緊急法案
然後川普
川普其實在美國弄緊急法案
去搞這個關稅這個事情
理論上來說 英文議會它全部控制了
但是議會也好幾次想去反駁它
就是包括我們覺得這次議會
也有可能會出一個議案
特別是參議院
可能會出個議案
說你這個關稅不能怎麼講
但是總統可能會否決它
那麼但是在其他國家
總統權力可能沒有那麼大
所以就是你要真的給中國加到關稅
這個125%
然後其他國家10%
讓這件事情從操作層面來說是很困難
很難的事情
甚至美國自己
它的這個就是關稅部門
有沒有能力把這個稅給收上來
或者是到時候收稅的時候
怎麼去看 它都不是那麼容易
但是比因賽這個是短劑
長期裡面來說
中美的關係就會慢慢的決裂
然後中美的貿易
特別是貿易關係
會每一份丟失的份都補不回來了
就是那個
就我上一周講的那個人員大戰的故事
一樣的道理
就是當你的那個兩邊民意
轟透到這裡的時候
其實政客們優化的是這個
是它那個
當然現在這個指數不是很好
但是這是CBS
CBS是極左媒體
那個政客優化的是它的支持率
優化的都不是經濟
所以特朗普我覺得現在也是
特別他優化甚至不是CBS這種民調
他優化的是福沃斯的民調
就是他優化的是在他的粉圈裡面
他支持那幫人
馬尷尬的幫人對他的Polaroid
那這個呢
這批人是非常就是非常誘的
非常就是你做這些事情
是能夠在他們那裡反而加分的
對於股票跌多少
經濟會不會好一點壞一點
有影響也是他的決策的原因
但是呢不是決定性的
所以在那個特朗普
把那個90天的Grace Parade
就是90天的那個延後
給到每個國家以後
就是他現在本來加了Reciprocal Tariff
給所有人
就非常高昂
上週可以看到的Reciprocal Tariff
大概是完整
是這個數字
對吧
然後把所有人除了中國以外
全部降成完整時
然後讓你們過去跟他談
那這個事情出來以後
有很多人說Navarro
這個Navarro會被當成替罪羊
然後因為這個
包括周末有傳聞說
把中國的半導體
半導體和電子產品的出口
那個關稅也降下來
那麼這個中間可能那個財政部長
起到了不少的作用
Belson起到不少的作用
但這個事情呢
我個人感覺不太可能
就是你要把那個Navarro從
Trump的核心團隊
或者支持團隊裡面給踢掉
然後把他當替罪羊
這件事情對於特朗普這樣一個政治人物
是不太可能
他不是奧巴馬
以前的傳統政客非常在乎
非常愛惜自己羽毛
而且非常就是說
愛惜自己羽毛同時話非常政治正權
所以他不希望有這種污點
有了這個污點之後
他要找一個人當替罪羊的
然後這件事情就你扛一下
然後我們就是改一個路徑繼續Move on
就是這樣路徑
特朗普不是
他身上污點就很多了
他所以他不在乎
他就是一種強人的形象
然後讓自己在他的粉圈裏
他的Maga圈裏加分
所以我們就說
你要理解他的這個Program
他的這個MetalNow的這個Program
他的這個Program呢
就是我優化的是這個東西
優化的是Program Rate
甚至我優化
不是我貼出來這個Program Rate
這個Program Rate下降了
這個英文是左派媒體了
他是喜歡福布斯媒體
或者是極右的那些人裏面的支持率
那這些人的支持率
不在乎他是不是政治正權
在乎於他是不是表現出一個政治強人
他是不是能夠繼續這樣
你看他星期一的時候就周末
不星期應該是星期
對星期的時候出來說
我們沒有宣布過給中國的
就因為星期五的時候
有很多的傳言說
電子產品這個稅收不收了嘛
就關稅就暫時下降
他說沒有說過這個事情
我們所有傳言比方說20%
對於電子產品
那個是當時芬太尼的Tariff
那現在整一個那個Reciprocal Tariff
把中國放到了一個Different Tariff Basket
然後除此之外呢
我們對於半導體和那個電子產品
還要搞一個National Security Tariff
這個是什麽東西
就是說美國說
他對於國家安全特別重要的那些產品
不能在其他國家生產
對於這些產品要加額外的關稅
這個關稅不光是對中國
這個關稅以後還對著臺灣對著其他地方
所以他並不是說
我把這一批關稅搞完就結束了
今天我把那個Reciprocal Tariff加上去就結束了
他我給大家看一下就是
我有沒有一個Tariff以前那個稅的一個圖
對這個
就是他並不是說我把中國
這裡這是以前高盛的預計
就是說我並不是說
我把這個Reciprocal Tariff這裡加上去就結束了
這個是預計加5%到10%
然後除了不是這個加了以後就結束
他還要去加比方說Critical Good Tariff
就是這裡塊
就是Critical Good就比方說重要產品
這個Steel and Aluminium
這個已經加過了
那麽這裡可能會加三米肯打肯
會加電子產品那些東西都會加上去
所以就是我覺得一個對市場基本上
要有一個判斷
就是當你在市場操作的時候
我在中搞就有個市場的判斷
我們在現在這個趨勢下
就好像非常像一個韓朔曲線
你只能取一條這個田井了
你只能取條切線
你並沒有辦法判斷到後面政策
我到底會怎麽走
所以你能我們能夠現在能做
就是根據這個這個切線來判斷
他後面就是現在政策下
他會變成什麽樣子
那麽現在政策他會變成什麽樣子
他會甩退的
他有50%的概率會甩退
為什麽呢
因為這個當時我覺得
這是比較保守最最早
2個星期前4月2號之前的一個高升的預期
你們看看哪些東西變化了嗎
就是這裡生活是20%的吧
現在是125
我們假設他最後能夠在20%塞透嗎
我覺得很難在20%塞透吧
就算大家把關稅都去掉
可能也是30幾對吧
所以這裡可能要加一個點
Receptical這裡加了10個點
所以這裡的預期是不足的加上去
那麽Critical Good
那這一塊預期10%
但是現在非常有可能看上去25%
就是對於那個Semiconductor
對於他那些認為Semiconductor
那個Electronic
然後再加上Famicillico
就是那個藥
藥電子產品和那個半導體
那麽這些有可能會加20%到25%的
所以你會看到整個Effective Tariff
跟它只是對於那些國家
就第一次公布那個所有的這個Effective Tariff
相比來說
其實好一些沒有好態度
這個是你看數字的一個基本判斷
就是說你最後再加上這些Tariff裡面
90天以後會不會有很多那個互相的制裁
比方說你制裁歐洲也會制裁你
你制裁你到了快到90天的時候
歐洲如果沒有制裁中國
或者說其他國家沒有制裁中國
你中國的商品還是可以通過
它不停的跑到你這裏來
那你是不是要把這條道給關掉
那麽這些事情就是會在90天的時間裏面
不停的被cook
就是不停的會被提起
這個中間是會有很多的風險
所以從基本面來看的話
你認為這個Tariff加上去
是不是會衰退
我覺得大概有50%的概率要衰退
就是即使現在這個Tariff
都有可能會50%的衰退
我們這個是Pricing
它90天之後還是會一直在10%
然後中國Tariff不是125
是會降下來
還是會50%的概率會衰退
所以說現在市場
有沒有Pricing這個衰退
就是我們說股票市場
資本市場有沒有Pricing
我認為是沒有的
就是S&P如果說
像我引用一下高盛的一個預期
高盛預期大概是今年3%的增長
然後市場預期待會比較高
市場預期8%到9%
那高盛對於衰退的這個判斷
大概是35%
就是預期35%
他認為是3%的增長
我認為是至少50%的概率要衰退
因為你一個百分點的Tariff increase
對應的就是0.1%的通漲
和0.1%的經濟負增長
所以這個一個是負
是個Based point
一個是通漲上升是個Based point
所以這個簡單 adding math
我們還不用去考慮
可能的資本市場的下跌
導致了經濟的一個自我實現的衰退
這些東西還沒有考慮進去
那麼我覺得就會讓通漲到3.5
然後讓經濟增長到1%
就現在這個東西就會讓經濟增長1%
那經濟增長1%以內的話
就有可能在一個季度裡面
發生比方說一個季度的衰退
那這個很正常
那麼在衰退的情況下
就我引用高盛的這個預期
高盛是預期S&P增長3%
所以每股收益253塊錢
然後那個2026年增長6%
每股收益265塊錢
那就從經濟基本面來說
它比我樂觀
然後我更悲觀一點
那麼就算269塊錢
用它的這個預測
你在真正衰退的時候
你會回頭看真正衰退的時候
2018年2020年
那麼這些時候它的PE值是多少
就是我們就算用Forward的PE
就明年的PE值是多少
那PE值一般是13、14、15
就特別差的時候是13
然後那個在衰退初期
可能就是14、15
那在衰退中那就反彈了
因為一般反彈都是在衰退中間的反彈
然後牛市都是在衰退中間開始做牛市
衰退不會到真牛市
但是衰退的預期和快衰退的時候是最慘
所以衰退預期的時候
應該經濟數據剛出來不好的時候
可能會到13、14
那你就用比方說14區計算的話
14計算
14你比20乘上269
到4000點我覺得很正常
就是說如果衰退的話
跌到4000點是很正常的SNP
那麼在這種情況下面
就是我覺得在一個牛市裡面
你要知道更多的消息
或者說你要知道更多的這個
因為大家都會白Story
你要知道更多市場預期和熱點
然後去做壓住
那麼你走在所有人前面
那這種時候你會獲得很好收益
所以很多新入行
特別是交易在這個資本市場時間不長的人
特別過去兩年的牛市裡面
抓了好很多錢
他可能的收益比我們高得多
因為他們可能有些信息
特別是華人做霸道體信息很多
然後這些信息的市場會買單
那麼就可以一直走到前面
但是在牛市的時候
雄市的時候其實是不一樣
雄市所有的故事沒有人買單的
就是你覺得這個故事很好
進去你被買掉
那市場根本不買單
市場在雄市的時候
基本上就是不要按照消息去交易
也不要按照內幕去交易
因為這些東西市場往往
你不知道整個宏觀會怎麼走
宏觀的這個情緒會怎麼走
在一個雄市裡面
就是看清他會不會衰退
或者是看清大的宏觀
你看著這個方向
我們現在看只能按照切線來看
就這個切線
現在這個切線就是會衰退的
但是他如果把這些政策全取消
那就不會
那等到他改變了
真的改變了
我們再看
但是至少在現在這個切線下面
他要衰退的情況下
不要進去
再說一次不要進去
不要去讀短線
更加特別不要去看著K線
說著這個交易的就是圖
然後說哪裡是支撐位
你就衝進去撥反它
這個是非常危險
死了很多很多人
一方面就是特朗普的政策
就是你看著所有量價的指標
都是一個基礎
就是整個市場相對來說比較平穩
沒有很多的信息面的
Jump to default
叫Jump出來的信息
或者是從聯儲和美國政府方面
都是希望給到市場一個預期
根據這個預期
然後來交易
現在明顯不是這種市場
現在這個市場
就是他要給到你不給你預期
然後給你一個surprise
老是喜歡給你surprise
所以這種情況下
而且整個經濟
如果你覺得會衰退的話
這種negative surprise
一兩次就會把你整個倉位清掉
所以我是認為
如果是有倉位是可以留著
就是說你並不一定完全清倉
因為你確實也不知道
他的政策會怎麼樣
你可以不清倉
留了一定的倉位
你繼續觀察
因為S&P
你不管確實美國的股票這東西
你不管跌到一個什麼價位
它最終還是會反彈
它只是時間比較長
但是你在這個時間中間
持股體驗會很差
那如果手上有足夠的現金的人
手上有
比方說我們一直在說要減倉
減倉
然後你手上有足夠現金
現金留著要等
等到
我可以說估值這個東西吧
就Varation或者PE
Varation這個東西
在短期裡是完全無效的
但是在長期裡是一定有效的
所以你要等到
你覺得這些東西夠便宜
現在的市場
肯定不是一個夠便宜的市場
就是如果你Pricing衰退的話
那麼在這個中間也會有個分化
就像我好像上次也說過這個事情
分化是在於
很多的市場裡面
市場有很多的標的
特別是高科技的標的
相對來說是會好很多的
我這裡可能沒有圖
但是我就說一下
我大概看法了
高科技的標的
為什麼是相對來說比較安全
因為它的一個公司
盈利或現金流的收益比較高
第二個它殺過一輪了
跌了很多
那麼在現在整個市場
我覺得你說它估值
還比較高嗎
美國市場估值比較高
估值我覺得是階梯的
估值最高的是香港
接的是歐洲和日本
接的是美國S&P
接的是S&P裡面的高科技
我覺得這麼排個序吧
你說S&P我們就光說美國
美國確實
就是它可能會殺腿
可能會跌S&P
但是歐洲應該跌更多
歐洲去年雖然說已經估值很低了
但是根據經濟的基本情況
你不同不能用美國的脾氣來逃中國和歐洲的
這個增長情況是完全不一樣
美國過去15年
經濟就是S&P為什麼這麼一直在漲
因為科技都在美國
好的公司和科技都在美國
新的科技都在它那裡
包括互聯網公司
幾個大的科技公司
包括所有的這個AR
和AR後面眼神應用
這些東西全部在美國
所以它的估值
確實這個體系跟其他國家是怎麼樣
這個科技領頭的這個狀態
美國會不會改變呢
雖然現在有什麼屈住移民的可能
然後減少中國留學生
但是本質上不太會
它的科技好有很多
Bound mental的原因
就這個基礎原因
所以不是那麼容易被改變的
所以我社會覺得
美國的科技和科技公司的
還是就是S&P
確實後面還是會有估值的
這個估值體系不能套到香港和歐洲
香港和歐洲現在被中國消費boost
然後歐洲的這個投資boost
這兩個東西能拖起來
所以真正的美國的估值
我覺得從我的看的估值體系
來看的話
Restable of the world
這個整體的估值體系
可能會比美國更加嚴重一點
就是更加悲觀一點
就是可能還是會悄悄
所以如果你們認為是
整個經濟要衰退的話
美國的衰退必然帶奔全世界
特別要帶奔中國
你瞄看120%的關稅
中國有50%的出口
最終的目的可能是美國
50%不到吧
這個40幾只好有的
雖然統計數據上是20%
但是實際可能有40%
但是更要敏的這個40%
是所有的外貿
甚至中國大部分製造業中間
最賺錢的部分
那麼你把這部分去掉
有一些企業
就好像一個企業三條業務線
那條業務線賺錢
能把另外兩條業務線給養活
你把那條最賺錢業務線跟停掉
你整個有多少人要失業
所以這個基本面上
它不是說我花點錢去刺激消費
甚至說多發點消費
但能解決的問題
這個在中國真解決不了
所以整個估值體系
我會反過來這樣看
就是美國可能好過
就是高科技公司好過S&P
但是這都高估了
然後S&P到中國和歐洲
這麼一個關係
那麼在雄市的時候關注自己說
不要去超短線
超短線
第一個沒有打兩個消息面
第二個所有的
我今天早上發了一個推特
也講到這個問題
所以你看K線的這些指標
其實是非常落後的
而且不是很有效的
所以再加上你看大的形勢
就好像這條曲線
大趨勢中間會反彈
但是大的趨勢
現在的政策趨勢它就要衰退
有衰退的話就不要去延續
那麼再說一下債
我覺得債的事情大家很敢進去
上週這五天裡面
國債的這個波動
利率的波動
基本上已經達到了2008年
或者2019年的時候
就只有這兩次是超過的
所以這麼大的時間紀律率
這麼大的這個波動
大家覺得有些人去懷疑說
美國是不是發債債太多了
然後下個月有很多債要買
那麼背後原因是什麼呢
我覺得是一個組合
這組合是有兩部分
一部分是技術上的
第二部分是基本面上
基本面上第一個
Tariff出來
PCE要上去
這個是固定的
PCE上去就是一個通脹預期要上去
那麼
這個是本身是對長端債影響
是要往上
幼的
利率是要往上
第二就是外國投資人的部分
因為放了Tariff
大家會覺得外國投資人以後
不會放那麼多的中美國國債
就是大家擔心會影響
美國國債的儲備低穩
但我覺得這個事情不太會
但是大家市場有這樣的定價和擔心
可能會導致外國投資人至少減少
那麼技術層面上有幾個
第一個有這樣的Fundamental
有這樣的基本面
那麼有很多外國投資人確實在拋售
那麼中間可能設計中國要好
有兩部分
一部分設計中國要好
第二部分設計一些日本的可能對沖基金
或有人說是Nautru Bank
日本農林金庫應該不是
日本農林金庫如果出問題的話
發生流動性危機的話
這個整個市場影響會遠遠超過現在
所以我覺得可能是日本幾個對沖基金
或者是農林金庫下面幾個對沖基金
那麼他們原來持有股票
同時也持有國債
股票跌了很多
那就倾倉的手把國債一起賣
所以再加上中國有持有很多的債
可能也在賣
就是中國給它點顏色看看
而且要賣了這些東西
以後回去互盤港股
因為你既然打起經濟戰的話
經濟貿易戰就跟經濟打仗似的
你既然打起仗的話
你的頭陣你總是不能人家反彈了很多
我們不反彈
所以它要繼續去互盤
所以這個過程中間會導致美元的 spread
就有些 spread trade
就是我做空短短短短的
然後做長短的
或者我拿短短的利率去氧圈
spread trade 被槓桿挺高的
而且我們之前
我其實我記得
我一直在群裡面勸大家不要去買TLT
不要去買長短展
不要覺得衰退就去買長短展
因為這個東西不是特別確定的
我記得我說
你覺得要衰退的話
你去賣CDS 對吧
得說你確實有很多人去做 duration trade
去做長短展
就買了長短展
甚至它就是那個戒斷賣場
那麼這些槓桿的頭寸被清倉
就是平倉
那麼這個平倉的時候
就導致長短利率上取得非常多
我們叫做 spread 和 basis
兩個影響
basis等於 repo rate 這些東西上升了
因為你這個東西也會反向導致整個系統的
因為去槓桿
整個系統流動性緊縮
流動性緊縮導致短短的這個利率
repo rate 上升
然後它再要去平倉
所以這個東西
市場的流動性也會反過來導致國債的問題
那麼但是就基本上的判斷
就是說這個東西
國債的這個會不會有 fundamental 的影響
我覺得不會
先說一個最最基本面的東西
你短期裡面大量的拋盤
你跌一下很正常
但是就好像你插一根針
整個對市場的影響是非常有限的
我給你組數據
cash 就是短期的債券
短期債券今年發行量
大概是1.7萬億
去年是1.97
大概2萬億
2萬億美元
然後那個二三年是2.9萬億美元
所以你說短期的量其實下來不少的
就是說今年其實發債壓力
和整個國債市場的供應面的這個壓力
沒有那麼大
我們叫net
純的就是近的要近發債
那近發債今年
我因為債券一般用 dbo 問來算
就是那個每一個基點的變化
對於國債價格的變化
叫 dbo 問
都用這個東西來算
今年是7.58億美元 dbo 問
然後去年是10億美元
你就這個量是非常大的
因為你一個 basis point 動了
動10億美元的價格
這個很大的去年是10億
今年就一個別臉
今年是那個7.6億吧
7.6億
所以下降了20%
那麼中國能賣出來多少券
你想想看中國能賣多少券
1000億券
你就算你1000億券
2年97
你賣出來能對市場造成多大影響
你中國賣幾千億的這個國債
對整個美股市場只有短期影響
並不造成今年整體供求失衡
或者是不會是因為你把你中國賣的這個債券
然後導致這個整個市場一下子
今年變了供應變了
整個改變它供應面了
這個是不太會的
看一下今年的這個供求
所以現在在4月份
這個圖是3月份的圖
我們沒有更新4月份的圖
這是3月份圖
所以在4月份的時候
整個國債供應面還是比較多的
但是到了5月份供應面就又下來
所以這個是有波風波鼓的緩和的過程
但是你看今年整年
就是你看這個白顏色的點
這個白顏色點是net
下面那個白顏色點是net
是純的supply
純的supply比去年是下降的
所以你可以說在三年五年的長洲期裡面
它的供應面是比較多的
就是國債會越來越需要越發越多
但是你在短期裡面來看的話
就是按今年來看
其實國債並不是一個大雄市
它的供應面並不大
那麼你短期裡面
你國債拋出來
你中國拋個幾百億
幾百億就可以讓市場
就是稍微動了十幾個basis point
很正常
但是你就算中國持續性的
把你手上國債全部拋掉
你不太會影響這個美債的市場
就是你不會對它造成災難性的結果
甚至美聯儲有很多的手段
不管你提供國債貼線也好
我給一個非常非常低的貼線利率
給一個國債貼線也好
讓你們去套利
然後或者我甚至
我這個甚至我不用買國債
我直接給很低很低貼線利率
然後讓你們去送錢給你們套利就好了
所以有很多的辦法去解決這個問題
我倒是不覺得
那個就是境外投資人的賣盤
會導致這個國債怎麼樣
所以當然了
現在價位應該已經下了一點
我記得好像最高是4.5 4.6
現在可能又回到4.4了
你這個水平上的borderline
就是一個比較公盈的估值
我覺得現在國債是一個相對來說
比較公盈的估值
你要去壓住它再會發生危機往上
我覺得也不一定
但是如果說你覺得美國會衰退的話
那麼我現在覺得CDS的定價還是不夠的
就是信用計差的定價還是不夠的
甚至股票的定價也是不夠的
所以這個東西有點我們叫coin flip
就是丟硬幣
我覺得就是55%的衰退概率
但是如果說是衰退
S&P應該你從估值角度來講
是有可能到4000年左右的
這個是一個很大的跌幅的
所以我是這個樣的建議
就是對於政策層面的判斷
我沒有辦法預期
我確實不是特朗普身邊的人
我個人感覺他是在一個自己粉圈的人
所以納瓦羅那些人是不會被取代的
他把財政部長換掉
他都不談回去
真的把納瓦羅怎麼樣
錢納瓦羅不能幫他蹲過監獄
所以特朗普的政策有一定的頭鐵性
但是中間會有很多bug
會來來回回的牽扯
他和中國之間的貿易戰
就我用兩個詞
我上次今天講的樣子就是蠶鬥
就是蠶在一起
糾葛在一起的鬥
然後那個中間有很多大氣機
日的這種反彈
消息變好
大家又談好了
又談不好
又談好又談不好
中間出bug了
然後修bug
來來回回來來回回拉扯
然後拉扯到最後
要市場什麼時候叫停呢
就是規矩疲倦
大家就疲了
就這個你不看了
然後該跌的跌差不多了
我就到這種狀態
我覺得財差不多結束
參考一下2015年的中國市場
就是中間也有很多很多反彈
鼓掷期貨拉漲停不是一天的
有的是
但是你那個時候是因為
整個中國去港港嗎
你背景不太一樣
但是你一樣去港港
那個時候的政策
中國取消了嗎
沒取消那就要點一樣
現在美國就是關稅的政策
他現在特朗普
你覺得特朗普想去幫馬卡
做的這些政策
對經濟是正面的還是負面的
他會不會取消
他會取消到哪一步
這個我沒有辦法判斷
沒有人能辦法判斷
除非他非常身邊的人
如果一定要我講的話
我覺得不太會取消
我覺得他頭很甜
所以我覺得衰退概率挺高的
我覺得現在市場還是處於
沒有完全定價微步風險的狀態
還是很危險
所以你有的倉位
就是你如果不高的有的倉位
你放在裡面看著
觀察性的
沒有我就放在看著
跌沒省跌了S&P
最終你時間問題
你最後還會回來
但是全倉的進去
或者是很快好的去抄底
我覺得免了就是要小心
好吧
這個我個人的看法
然後